there are a bunch of apps that are
popping up that are purely to give us
online anonymity if that actually exists
we've got a list of a couple of them
there's conf ID which erases your text
messages right after they're red there's
whisper which shares secrets anonymously
and there is yet yak anonymous social
chat room so this is perfect considering
the topic we were just talking about so
going to your point of the circle which
if you guys are watching if you haven't
seen the clip right before this will
annotate so you can get right back over
there about everyone being completely
transparent with everything is that is
the anonymity thing the next thing
before that you know I mean first we
have to first it's we put all the stuff
out there which we're all doing now next
it'll be we'll all do it anonymously and
there's plenty of people doing that
already and then after that we get to
the place of total everything else it
doesn't surprise me that this is a trend
right now but didn't we start with the
internet kind of having this didn't we
didn't isn't that how people started in
these chat rooms that it was anonymous
and people were talking to each other
under you know some fake screen name and
now because of things like Facebook and
Instagram and you have a profile picture
it became a little more public it's
strange to me because we've become this
this culture of sharing and we have
become narcissistic in a way like we
want everyone to know our ideas and our
thoughts it's strangers or anything a
selfie quick one coast it's whatever my
new is where we are what's going on
exactly but it's it's strange to me that
people feel the need to share their
deepest darkest secrets with their
friends without their friends knowing
exactly who they are I mean what happens
to conversations you know if the
argument is well if somebody is having
an issue with substance abuse or if
someone is having a real personal
problem what happened to actual personal
contact where you confide in somebody
and say I need your help and instead of
putting it out there for all of your
friends to judge and then sit and
discuss I know that it's anonymous but
your friends you know they're going to
get together and say do you think that
that was Bobby do you think that I think
that he would be the person who said
that this is like gossip on a weird new
level I don't think it will I
hope it doesn't last because it seems
like it's opening a door to more
negativity than positivity so but could
there be something cathartic about this
online anonymity thing I mean if you had
a nap if you were just having a crazy
day and frustrated by something and you
didn't want to tweet it with your name
attached to it you know something really
angry that you could just click on one
of these things get it out there and
feel a little better and move on would
you like that the thing with the whole
online it's just that everybody being
online everybody's opinion matters just
as much as everybody else's opinion and
it requires increasing levels of cruelty
just to keep up go to any video on
youtube check out the fourth commenters
comment it always rips the third
commenter because the fourth commenter
is always a jerk and the fifth guy the
newcomer tries to find common ground
among everyone and for that for that the
six commenter impugns his sexuality so
at you know they also say that the
problem with anonymity online is that it
kid creates bullies right you could
bully but let's remember who's the
biggest victims of bullying it's the
bullies right there ostracized are
stigmatized and their Creed trees like
monsters in society into all the bullies
out there I just want to say it gets
better do we need anonymity now more
than ever because of all the NSA's look
I don't even believe that any of these
apps truly work because I'm pretty sure
that if the government wants to get in
there and figure out that they can
somehow track it to your IP address on
your computer or something related to
your phone but let's pretend for a
second that these things truly are
anonymous is there any at that point
then it has some worth right because we
need to be able to share secrets and
with everything going on at the NSA but
why do we need to share secrets online
this is what range to me if you're
thinking about putting your information
out there online you need to assume that
at some point somebody's going to figure
out exactly who it is if you want to
maintain anonymity if you want to keep
your ideas anonymous why should I put
them out there online and just under
some shield you know so what about
somebody for example that's working for
the NSA now let's say that there's
things that Snowden hasn't revealed that
they know are even worse something like
this would be a legitimate way of
getting it out there well and you but
you think that with our technologies
well that's my point i don't believe
that that it would work follow the trail
in the IP address your right and figure
out exactly who that was like maybe i
wouldn't be able to figure it out just
sitting on my computer reading this
anonymous quote but if somebody wants to
figure out who made this post yeah i
mean google keeps everything that you
ever searched for i mean if you really
want to go for it it would be possible
to get that kind of information and
again that's the risk that we run in
living this technology in this world
where everything is accessible we it's
the weird price that we pay for the
convenience that we strangely want and
for the my opinion matters feeling that
we all seem to strangely 1 i'm not
saying that we all do but that as a
society not seem to public people
talking about our feelings on time not
us no no we're fine uh yeah I mean do
you think that there's some worth two in
it in a day and age of the NSA and
spying all that do you think there if if
they couldn't track the stuff that
there's some worth to it I think there's
I mean you know many times I wished I
was anonymous online to be able to say
certain things so I you know instead of
having to re sign in to Google under a
fake name and then go to that commenter
on YouTube and rip him a new [ __ ] can
you just write your fake name here so I
can vaguely what you've been writing
about me my fake name is Jim door yeah
yeah people don't know your history you
know it's funny every time I have you on
the show there's this guy Jim door who's
like that jimmy dore each he goes nuts
for it fantastic